[Music]
[Applause]
fred siegel has a new book it's called
freezing cold takes
nfl football media's most inaccurate
predictions and the fascinating stories
behind them
it's a book that was released yesterday
and uh fred kind enough to join us
i'd probably refer to you as the
ombudsman of sports media is that a fair
title
i'm one of them
i think there's others too i think
everybody likes to fashion themselves in
some ways that budsmen of sports media
uh the tweet that got the most traffic
most attention was what
oh god
there's so many um there's one
in particular that i can think of that's
really really funny
it's from cal herd
colin cowherd in
let me say uh 2014 he posted
uh dak prescott will be a backup in the
nfl period
at tight end period
and it consistently goes around and
around and around
and is made fun of constantly
and that almost feels like a joke
like it's so absurd that you're trying
to have fun with it i mean this isn't
logan thomas who became a tight end
after being a quarterback in college i i
think he was i think it was a little
hyperbolic he was watching a game where
mississippi state was playing alabama
and
dak prescott wasn't playing well
and he was basically saying he's not
going to be amount to anything in the
league
but the way he said it was just to make
fun of him and to really get the eye of
michigan st i mean mississippi state
fans the difference between a hot take
and a bold prediction is what
well the difference between a hot take
is something that
i would say is
you are trying to say something in a way
that is
um not just bold but
is going to be provocative enough to get
attention and
bold prediction is simply just the
blanket prediction so i would say a bold
prediction is sometimes within a hot
tape
but then there's part of it do you feel
like you're being played by those giving
these hot takes because
they want it to be crazy they want it to
be outlandish that they're trolling you
yes i try to i try to evaluate that a
lot uh because like guys like skip
bayless you
uh there are people who think that
that's his entire all of his take
repertoire is that
um but i i do understand that there's a
lot of these guys on tv who were trying
to be interesting
more than trying to be right
but um at the end of the day
everybody's sending me those takes so at
least like just a substantial amount of
people are trying to get those takes
appearing on the feed so i say to myself
i'll do some of them but not all
like i'm not going to just use
everything skip bayless says or cowherd
says
i have to put a limit on it and there's
a lot of other people who do that yes
skip bayless the first face on your
mount rushmore of
cold takes well in protest because of
the reasons you say
skip is is there's things that he posts
that are completely obvious that he's
doesn't he can't possibly think of those
things think those things rationally
and he also has his
what feels to be a a gimmick a stick
where he
zeroes in on a player and decides i'm
going to
constantly
berate that player and say negative
things about him and spin any positive
into a negative
and obviously
his biggest one is lebron james he does
that with and in nfl he does that with
aaron rodgers
and he does that in a lot of other
sports too
he
anything aaron rodgers does he'll spin
it even if it's positive it'll spin it
into a negative
and so it doesn't seem like it's genuine
all right so you have skip bayless who
else is on your mount rushmore well i
would say mike francesa
um but mike is trying to be right he's
not trying to troll you
exactly and that that's what i wanted to
that's that's what that's a great point
out of all the people who are trying to
be provocative on air
and
really concerned about
uh being entertaining
francesa is completely honest with
everything he says
but he's so defiant
he's so defiant about what he says
he'll say things and just
it's like there's no way that anyone
else who thinks it could possibly be
right and he he has a knack for saying
things that
uh in defiantly and then after
like within
a real brief period the opposite happens
like he defiantly said that the jets
would never get two first-round picks
for jamal adams and then like
less than 24 hours later the jets traded
adams to seattle he got two first rounds
like
like he has a knack for having that
happen to him but i gotta give him
respect because at least like he's not
trying
no like he's genuine in his in how bad
some of his opinions are he's genuine in
everything he says he has no
he he doesn't think about that uh about
the
being provocative and yeah like exactly
what
you'd see a lot from all these people in
in sports radio and sports tv now so
you've got cow herds on your mount
rushmore i'm guessing um yeah cowards on
there but you know coward
coward he i i think that he wants to be
interesting first but he he's his
things he says are are
genuine i i just think that he
fashions it in a way to be less boring
so and he likes to do those analogies
like he'll compare someone to like jeans
or boy bands
um
i think he compared he compared he
compared nick
foles season for philadelphia in 2018
to adam sandler's
monologue in billy madison
where billy madison said the puppy who
lost his way when he was sitting in the
kindergarten class
that he went all the way and dug there
about that was nick foles the puppy who
lost his way i'd have to blame that on
his writing staff because i
i i don't think that's colin i think
that's writing stats he does that he
loves the metaphors
i can imagine his writers come up with a
metaphor show it to him comparing like
uh steph curry to skinny jeans
and
then tell him going perfect yeah
uh i can run with that all right give me
some other ones you mentioned uh
cow herds one on dak prescott skip
always has a couple of them
your five favorite ones
okay well one of the ones your favorite
is my favorite is uh
is you know
the patriots will regret hiring bill
belichick is the
is the headline
to uh
article written by ian o'connor who was
then
a writer for the westchester daily news
in new york
um he gets all the he's like the fall
guy for that tape
but
if you read my book and as you'll see in
my book
there are
so many of those people who thought that
yeah i mean i have a whole chapter just
of course and that's pre-social media so
he's grandfathered
all newspaper yeah
all right what other takes do you have
um well there's
uh
one
skip bayless said johnny football will
one day be bigger in cleveland than his
buddy lebron ever was
that was right after
johnny manziel was drafted
by cleveland browns
late in the first round i think it was
um is he still sticking by that no no he
doesn't stick by then okay i just wanted
to make sure he he used it he constantly
pushes pushes push until he can no
longer do it anymore
um but i know that he was big on tebow
over aaron rodgers that he would take
right right he was big on tebow over
here he was big on tebow about
everything he picked tebow as one of his
guys just like he has guys that he
doesn't like and he will be critical of
them about everything he does the exact
opposite with certain other guys and
tebow was one of them he just hitched on
the tibo wagon and just completely
uh
talked him up like everything he did was
gold and that was one of the things he
did with tebow and then until it until
it finally wore off and he couldn't do
it
yeah i don't know what skip is going to
do when lebron retires
i'll have to pick another guy but i
think that that take right there that
johnny football one
was a way to
you know hitch on to johnny denzel and
then also
criticize lebron at the same time what
uh what freezing cold takes do you have
when the falcons were up 28 to three
oh god i i there's so many i remember
jim rome said
shootout question mark blow out
rack him
yeah
rackham uh
uh there were there were so many i mean
it was so long ago but at the time
um the funny thing was at the time i was
preparing
all the posts about the falcons at
halftime and then by the end of the
third quarter i started to have to
pick up all the ones from the beginning
of the game
uh
in the first half i was preparing all
the things about people saying the
falcons wouldn't win because i thought
they were gonna win so it was really
like my actions were a cult take on my
part
during that game then i came to the mid
third quarter i had to start to
recyc go back and look at all the posts
about
28.3 halftime but there were so many i
mean stephen a smith definitely had one
talk about brady being done there was a
lot about trying to put in jimmy
garoppolo
should they put in jimmy garoppolo
and also about trump like trump
brady was friends with trump
because that was a big thing at the time
so he has to lose because trump makes
everything bad that type of thing
well good luck with the book freezing
cold takes nfl football media's most
inaccurate predictions and the
fascinating stories behind them
uh fred thanks for joining us i'm glad i
didn't make the book
well you don't really go on the hot
takes you're one of the ones you're one
of the few who is able to
not have to do that
and still
has a very popular show well i also had
the luxury of being on sportscenter
right right you were able to have
credibility going into i think it would
be a harder thing to do now to try to
break into the radio business not being
that guy i'm gonna try to make the next
book fred all right all right
thank you bud
take care that is the man who collects
freezing cold takes there
a twitter media critic fred siegel a
book is now available
came out yesterday
i'm happy i didn't make it